welcome to the show everybody we begin
today with a story that is so
incomprehensible insane that even the
most cynical and jaded among you will
have a hard time believing at me as the
most cynical and most jaded I found it
hard to believe somebody emailed the
story to me it's the first I'd heard of
it and before I click the link I thought
based on the description in the email I
thought wow there's got to be more to
this there's no way no no way then I
click the link and I find out no this is
exactly it
the headline in the Des Moines Register
convicted of sex crimes as a man felon
no longer deemed threat because of
gender change translation a man who
raped 15 children including a
one-year-old baby is now getting out of
prison because he claims to be a woman
this is really happening this is really
happening in the United States in the
year 2020 so I want to get into the
details of this case and then break down
just how outrageous this really is I
know it seems like there's no need to
explain why it's outrageous but it
because it's self-evident it would seem
but this case is so unjust so
preposterous that there are levels of
lunacy you may not notice at first it's
like some sort of grotesque onion where
you pull back one layer and there's
another and another another we'll talk
about that in just a moment but first a
word from a new show sponsor I'm excited
to talk to tell you about that's Daniels
we all say don't judge a book by its
cover but we also know that's exactly
what most of us do appearance can be
everything especially in a professional
situation so whether it should be the
case or not it is which is why I want to
talk to you about that bag that you have
over your shoulder right now perhaps are
you carrying maybe an old college
backpack to work or around town if you
have to go to the coffee shop like I do
often with my laptop and so on if so
it's really time to grow up and look the
part and get yourself a Daniels
briefcase based in New York City
Daniel's makes leather briefcases for
the modern professional and they're
making boys look like men one bag at a
time that's
that's the goal here made from premium
Italian leather Daniels is the perfect
bag for wherever the day happens to take
you Daniels is designed in New York City
with working professionals in mind it's
a bag that's built for for real life
that means it's high-quality it's
durable it's a simple design it's not
there's no flashy logos or anything but
it's a it's a great style as well so
it's exactly what you want you got the
utility you got the style as well I
could tell you that Daniels conducted
kind of an intervention on me because
I've been toting around the same
tattered book bag for about six years
now
I bought one six years ago and give him
as I said what I do for a living I'm I
have to have my laptop with me pretty
much everywhere I go so I had this I had
this old crusty rotting decaying book
bag that I always had with me Daniel's
sent me one of their beautiful
briefcases and finally finally I look
like a grown man
thank God it's about time 33 years old
so I love I love the the feel of the
leather the attention to detail even the
inner lining of the briefcase is
beautiful so everything about it I
couldn't recommend it enough this week
my listeners can get $50 off their
Daniels briefcase at Daniel's NYC comm
by using promo code Walsh at checkout
that's 50 bucks off one of their leather
briefcases take advantage of this deal
now plus they offer free shipping free
returns free exchanges what else do they
have to do to get you to buy one of
these briefcases again that's Daniels
NYC comm promo code Walsh for $50 off a
handcrafted high-quality leather
briefcase with free shipping start
looking like a professional today
Daniels NYC comm
I love carrying their briefcase and I
know you will too okay let's get back to
this situation I've got to read to you
basically this whole story of the Des
Moines Register as reported by Tom
Cullen the reporter because I just you
need I want to give you all the details
about this all right
so the Iowa attorney general's office is
the Des Moines Register the Iowa
attorney general's office is no longer
seeking the commitment of a former
Midwest Christian services student
convicted of myriad as sex crimes
because the individual now identifies as
a woman
court records show the state dismissed
the application on january 9th attorney
general spokesman lynn hicks
wouldn't comment on the reason for the
dismissal other than to say an
offender's hormone levels are an
important part of substantiating and
offenders likelihood of recidivism in
November the Storm Lake Times reported
that Joseph Matthew Smith a 23 year old
convicted of molesting a fellow MCs
student in 2014 was undergoing medical
treatment that is needed prior to
potentially undergoing gender
reassignment surgery
Smith has received treatment for gender
reassignment over the past two years at
Newton Correctional Facility she first
expressed I'm reading the article so I'm
gonna be using the pronoun she' to
describe this man but every time I say
she in your head put the scare quotes
around it okay she first expressed a
desire to get started on transgender
classification in October 2017 and
started using female pronouns Smith has
expressed a preference to identify its
Josie according to court documents Hicks
said that we don't believe we have
evidence sufficient to prove Josie Smith
has a significant chance of reoffending
an Iowa Department of Corrections
spokesman said Smith was transferred on
Saturday to the Sioux County or the
sioux city residential treatment
facility for transitional release Hicks
cautioned the public not to overreact to
Smith's upcoming release Smith will be
subject to sex offender registration for
the rest of her life Hicks said which
includes regular meetings with a
probation officer and a listing on an
attorney General Clearing House so don't
worry yes he's a serial sex offender but
he's gonna be on a list and he's gonna
have meetings so don't be concerned
Josie Smith according to Hicks says we
will be will be subject to strict sex
offender reporting required of those who
commit the crime she did
she'll be subject to supervision for the
rest of her life a preliminary report
prepared by the state's expert dr.
Jeffrey Davis says Smith molested as
many as 15 victims ranging from ages 1
to 13 before being sentenced to prison
in December 2015 the report found the
likelihood of reoffending within 5 years
of release exceeded 20% because victims
were of both genders and because Smith
was under the age 25 and never had a
long-term relationship his myth has has
not had an intimate relationship the
report says his sexual encounters
appeared to have primarily involved
molestation including his own
molestation by multiple perpetrators or
his victimization of others he was
molested as a child starting at the age
of seven okay and then it goes on from
there I'm saying there's any other
details here that are that are important
dr. Tracey Thompson Thomas a forensic
psychologist said that the statute that
outlines civil commitment requires the
state to essentially prove an offender
has a chance offending greater than 51%
for the rest of his life that becomes
harder to prove when her defender
significantly lowers his his
testosterone levels which has a
significantly higher impact on sex drive
than estrogen okay where do we even
begin as I said there are many layers of
this putrid rancid onion so in no
particular order let's start here first
of all it's not even true that this man
this man this dude this male individual
this male scumbag I should say it's not
true that he's less likely to
reoffending to a female quote unquote
that's simply not true in fact they
actually did a study on this a
legitimate study well the the the
longest and most involved study of its
kind as far as I know where they it
involves 324 people over the course of
30 years and they looked at whether
there was any change in of several
different things but including
criminality reduction in crime including
violent crimes for transgenders who
transitioned from male to female and
they found no they found that these male
to females retain the same rate of
violent crime as regular males probably
because they're still male at the end of
the day second
even if it was true it's beside the
point even if it was true that his
chances of reoffending have now been
somewhat or even significantly
diminished because he's on these hormone
pills that's would still be beside the
point
it's it's irrelevant because we're
missing something here and it's a big
thing and that that thing is called
justice the point of prison is not
simply to segregate dangerous people so
that so that you know when they're
supposedly not dangerous anymore we can
release them that's not the whole point
that's that's part of the point
segregation of dangerous people is part
of the point of prison it's not the
entire point not even close to the
entire point and it's not the main point
if it was then why is somebody like I
don't know Bernie Madoff still in prison
he's probably not a danger to anybody
anymore
is he still if he's still alive I mean
is he still haven't much sure but if he
is he's probably not a danger to danger
anybody anymore yeah he scammed hundreds
of people out of their life savings but
probably he wouldn't be able to do it
again after he's famous for doing it the
first time and so release him from
prison put him on a scam artist registry
and you know then he does then he can go
about his life we could have a registry
for everything a murderer registry car
car thief registry no need for prisons
anymore in fact with murder think about
think about it just as a hypothetical
example but one that has many analogous
cases think about someone say a man in
his 50s who murders his wife in a fit of
passion after finding out that she
cheated on him okay what are the chances
that that guy will kill somebody else
he's not a serial killer
he's not even necessarily a psychopath
let's say he lived the first 50 years of
his life never hurt anybody so what are
the chances that he does it again
I probably less than I would say
significantly less than 50% so if you're
letting this guy out of prison why put
people
murder others in a crime of passion in
prison their risk of killing again is is
pretty low probably well that doesn't
work because for one thing being on a
registry having your name on a database
doesn't do a single damn thing to
prevent you from committing a crime for
another it's not only about crime
prevention it's about justice justice
matters to a lot it matters a lot so I
don't care if you can look into a
crystal ball and tell me that this dude
will never hurt another child child
again you can't and if you did have a
crystal ball telling you that then I
would say your crystal ball is defective
because he will do it again will people
who are serial child molesters people
who get into their 20s and as the report
says they have had have had many sexual
interactions but all of them are
molestation whether to him or by him
people like that they don't snap out of
it you let him out of prison in his
early 20s he's not gonna spend the rest
of sixty years of it you know the final
60 years of his life or however however
long he lives on the straight and narrow
it's not gonna happen because we're
dealing with someone who is sick and
dangerous this is a sick and dangerous
person and sick and dangerous people
don't magically suddenly stop being that
but again regardless of that justice the
man deserved to be punished for what he
did because that is justice you molest a
child you molest a one-year-old
for God's sake justice calls for you to
be in prison forever never to see the
light of day again in fact justice calls
for a short walk up the gallows and then
an even shorter trip back down with a
rope around your neck that's what it
calls for this guy shouldn't even be
living anymore he should be he should he
should be executed that's what we should
be doing with serial child molesters I'm
very much convinced of that
but at a minimum justice calls for
permanent life incarceration there is no
benefit to society at all to being
lenient on child molesters third point
this man was molested as a child that's
not an excuse for what he did but my
point is he was molested as a child and
then he became a serial child molester
and then he goes to jail and then he
decides he's really a woman do you think
that revelation was due to some deep
insight this guy has about his interior
self do you think all of these details
in fact that he's a sexual degenerate
who was abused as a child you think
that's irrelevant to the sudden
identification as a woman even if it's
true that a man can really be a woman
inside whatever that whatever the hell
that means
even if that was true which it isn't but
even at what even if it was does any
sane person think that that's the case
for this particular guy isn't it
incredibly obvious that he is just a
confused sick depraved human being and
his desire to live as a woman is yet
another one of his perverse fantasies
isn't that obvious to everybody with a
brain again regardless of how you feel
about transgenderism generally the
reality in this specific case should be
obvious to everybody and he gets to
leave prison because he transitioned I'm
sure that had nothing to do with it
right the fact that he gets to leave now
because he transitioned
just like the guys who discover their
inner femininity and then what do you
know get to walk into a women's locker
room but we're told no that's got
nothing to do with it they would never
be motive nobody would ever be motivated
by that so if you transition you get to
get you can get out of jail free you can
go into women's locker rooms but no no
no no
that's it that would never be anyone's
motivation ever no no no it could never
ever have it's impossible right forth
point and yet in spite of all this the
person who wrote the article I just read
and the officials interviewed in the in
the article least one of the officials
they all reverently use the pronouns
that this sicko this baby rapist wants
why
do you actually think he's a woman is
that really what you think the guy who
wrote this article and is using the word
sheet you really is that really you
think this guy's a woman is that you you
really believe that if not why are you
barking like a dog and using the
language he demands why are you barking
on command on this guy's command he says
call me a woman okay then I will why you
can't even look at this guy and say
sorry sorry buddy no okay what you want
makes no difference to me but you don't
wanna hurt his feelings
you don't hurt the feelings of a man who
molested a child multiple children
that's your concern you're gonna
sacrifice truth you're gonna sacrifice
rationality you're gonna sacrifice your
dignity you're gonna humiliate yourself
embarrass yourself and play along with
this nonsense
all simply to preserve the feelings of a
child rapist really how spineless can
you be this is beyond spineless this is
this is boneless you are now a
gelatinous puddle of a person laying
there flaccid and helpless with no will
of your own then you would actually
debase yourself by using this person's
preferred pronouns fifth point let's um
let's not allow the judicial malpractice
involved in releasing this man from
prison distract from the gem the
malpractice involved in the fact that he
was allowed to transition in prison
in the first place on the taxpayers dime
remember what it said Smith has received
treatment for generate assignment over
the past two years at Newton
Correctional Facility so this guy molest
15 kids goes to jail gets a free gender
transition out of the bargain is now
released again and and and here again we
have we have the feelings that confused
arranged feelings of a pedophile give an
absolute top billing top priority what
is the argument in favor of you of using
tax money to help this guy transition
there's no argument other than it would
make him feel good and he would feel bad
if he couldn't do it that's the argument
that wins the day that outweighs
everything else and once again why does
he want to transition is it because he's
identified some mysterious mystical
truth about his inner self or is it
because this is another one of his six
sexual fantasies what which do you think
we now have prisons spending money tax
money to help pedophiles live out their
fantasies in prison what if he wanted to
be a furry would you go and get them a
dog costume well if we had a BDSM thing
would you build them a sex dungeon I
mean how far does this go
this is there are we are at a point
where literally no words can adequately
describe how crazy things have gotten
and maybe you have the same feeling I do
but every day I feel like there's
there's a small collection of sane
people left in this country and every
day another person abandons the same
tribe and I always feel such betrayal
when they do it and one way I know is
that you know I see yet another person
who I thought I thought was who I
thought was rational and had a little
bit of of a spine you know I see them
talk
think about a case like this and saying
the word she and every time I see that I
think I think e - E - brute a you're
gonna do it - really I mean am I the
only one who sees how am I the only one
who can look at someone like this and
say I'm like I don't give a damn what
your preferred languages I'm gonna say
what the reality is I don't care about
the fantasy world you're living in you
you cannot force me to pretend I don't
understand reality it's not gonna happen
6th point the hormone pills
this guy is given are supposedly so
potent that they're supposed to have
changed a sex predator into a non
predator they didn't as we stipulated
they didn't and even if they did as we
stipulated he should still be in jail
but it is true in any case that these
hormone pills are indeed extremely
potent and they do have a profound
lasting effect on the people who take
them that is true no doubt about that
so consider the fact that these same
pills the pill that is supposed to have
essentially chemically castrated this
sex offender in prison and made it so
that he is neutered and no longer a
danger to the public that same drug is
given to children children middle school
kids and younger are given the same drug
this guy has the same drug that is
supposed to have neutered a serial child
molester that that drug we give to
actual children because they're confused
they're confused about their gender and
so we give them this drug
I just I could go on
dissecting everything that's wrong with
this story and society but you get the
point and this is why it's so important
we the the few remaining sane people if
you're if you're in you know the same if
we're in the same Club if we're in the
same club you gotta you gotta you gotta
stay with us it's really important
sanity that's what we need in this
country now forget about everything else
you know we're not at the point yet
where we can have arguments making a
stand for things like patriotism and the
even morality what we're not there yet
we need to establish basic sanity basic
rationality and logic that's what what
what needs to be defended first before
we can get to anything else but this is
where it leads and this is why I
emphasize this issue so much because it
is a it is a war over reality itself
that's what's at stake and when they
insist that you start using certain
language that isn't true and those sorts
of things what they're saying is we
demand that you abandon reality that you
put feelings over truth that you put our
political agenda this is the left you
know you put our political agenda over
truth and reality and for some reason
every day more and more people find
themselves persuaded somehow I've had
argument all right let's I think we'll
go right to emails because I had a few
other stories but they're all in the
same vein of outrageous things that make
me angry but I think maybe just this one
for the day will be enough so that I
don't have a an aneurysm on camera
which would be interesting for the
viewer i I admit but I'd prefer I'd
prefer not so we'll go to emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com before we get though there
though you know we've been telling you
about the pro-life fight and and what
the daily wire has been doing and you
know obviously you know that for me on
this show the the struggle to defend
unborn life is the most important thing
60 million children killed since roe v--
wade and that's why this is the number
one civil rights issue of our time the
number one human rights issue of our
time one of the most important human
rights issues of all time but we also
know that the left has been has been as
it has been increasingly going off the
deep end
getting more extreme in their defense of
child murder and part of that effort is
also to censor and shut down those of us
who stand for for life and and and you
know to defend those who can't defend
themselves and so they've been going
after the daily wired we know that you
know when Ben Shapiro spoke at the March
for Life last year our advertisers were
targeted by left-wing media watchdogs we
lost revenue there and that these are
efforts that continue but we're not the
only ones live action is one of the
biggest pro-life voices in the movement
and they do some of the most important
work in the movement and they've also
been targeted continuously over and over
again relentlessly by the pro-abortion
set and there are entire social media
platforms they're no longer allowed on
that's why our daily wire.com members
are so important your membership helps
keep our cameras on our microphones
turned up even when the left pressures
our sponsors that's why from now until
January 31st a portion of any daily
wired.com membership will be donated to
live action with promo code live action
to support awareness and education
around the world in this issue this is
your last chance so head on over to
daily wire.com and make your pro-life
voice heard there's only a few days left
to take advantage of this plan and you
want to do it now so again join daily
wire.com make your pro-life voice heard
before it's too late
all right let's go to emails
this is from Brandon says dear Matt
first I must say you appear to have good
taste in most things drink entertainment
books and so on but if I did always fall
short of what is truly great your
affinity for Christopher Nolan and
whiskey choices are just a few examples
I know this marks for me for immediate
execution upon your ascension to
rightful rule as theocratic overlord
but hey you really can't do anything
about it right now anyway after the
glutton for second-best I took your
advice and had to listen to John Prine
the first song I listened to was hello
in there
I found myself blinking back tears
perhaps perhaps it was the fact that I
just found out my first child is going
to be a boy or perhaps I need to
re-evaluate your status as picker of
second best things either way thank you
for the suggestion Brandon I am because
I'm so merciful I'm going to overlook
all of those vicious insults you leveled
at me and simply say you're welcome for
pointing you in the direction of good
music and also for the record because I
don't like being slandered I don't know
where you get this my affinity for
Christopher Nolan thing I think my
position has been that I think
Christopher Nolan many of his films are
overrated I think is a good director
good filmmaker but you might be
confusing with bent with ben shapiro
he's the Christopher Nolan guy I'm not
I'm not really I'm kind of I'm lukewarm
on Nolan for the record this is from
Mark says hey Matt you posted on Twitter
about spanking kids and I wanted to
answer that I posted a Twitter poll for
people if they is is is spanking a child
is that a ethical and effective form of
punishments but interesting about 30,000
people have responded to the poll and
last I checked it was about I don't know
75 25 in favor of spanking kids back to
mark he says I find that he says I want
to answer that I spanked my kids I find
that is an extremely effective method of
raising my kids well my kids are usually
the most well-behaved kids in the room
or other parents and people are
constantly commenting on how
well-behaved my kids are especially my
daughter when I stopped using spankings
for time my kids behavior became
noticeably worse so I resumed there were
a few times when I overheard her talking
to her cousins while they were plotting
to do something mischievous and she said
I'm not going to do that because I'll
get a spank
I think it's important to do spanking
right you should do it in anger you need
to be consistent and you should talk to
your kids about what's going on and why
it's happening
with my kids I sit them down we talk
about the wrong behavior they did the
consequence then we do it that the
spanking then we talked to them about
what happened while comforting them and
finished with a prayer for strength
going forward I'm not going to say not
spanking is the wrong choice but I think
to say it is wrong to do it is
inappropriate also when you mentioned
studies the problem with the studies
done on this subject is that there is no
causal relationship between spanking and
negative outcomes the most that can be
that can come from it is a correlation
dr. Gershon ease on physical punishment
have some shortcomings quote
unfortunately all research on parent
discipline is going to be correlational
because we can't randomly assign kids to
parents for an experiment all right mark
yeah it's true that studies on the
subject are hard to conduct a real study
a real controlled study of something
like this would have to involve not
necessarily randomly assigning kids to
parents but randomly assigning parents
to spank their kids you have to have a
group of parents and you say okay this
group over here you're gonna spank your
kids this group you won't and then we'll
check back in ten years and see how it's
going but that would be obviously
unethical among all the other problems
with it so that hasn't been done so it's
a hard thing to study and that's why my
perspective on it doesn't hinge on
studies my point in bringing up the
studies was just to address all the
people who claim that spanking leads to
more disciplined kids and more
well-behaved kids and I don't think
there's any empirical evidence for that
there aren't any studies as you point
out I just I don't think there's any
evidence and and although studies of
this are hard to conduct and aren't
conclusive you can still you could still
look at various factors and broadly
compare spanked kids to non spanked and
that's been done and I don't think these
spanking leads to better behaved kids
theory has been supported by any of the
studies I or any of the research that I
that I've looked at my issue and
I think we've talked about this before
but my issue with spanking is
multifaceted number one there's a real
do as I say not as I do element to this
I tilma I tell my kids all the time
use your words don't hit I'm constantly
telling them that and then but I'm gonna
turn around and hit them
I can then I can insist all I want that
no it's different it's it's not the same
blah blah blah but a hit is a hit and I
think I under mine my own authority and
my message as a parent when I do the
thing I'm telling them not to do that
doesn't mean that everything I do a kid
should be allowed to do but if I'm
saying that something sort of in
principle is wrong and I have if I have
this consistent message of don't do this
don't do this too
then I shouldn't be doing it myself I I
can I can think of very few exceptions
to that another one would be yelling and
shouting I tell my kids all the time
don't yell don't shout do I do it myself
sometimes yes but I also know that it's
I shouldn't be because I'm I'm the one
constantly telling them not to do it I
if I do it and I tell them not to kids
are gonna make a connection it does all
as I said all we want we can say that's
different now but bla bla that's not how
they see it
number two I think spanking may kind of
reek of desperation a really in command
and in control parent should be able to
instill discipline and keep a handle on
things without resorting to hitting
their children and I can't remember who
said about red somewhere somebody drew
this I thought interesting distinction
between being a demanding parents and
being a commanding parent and the
distinction is anybody can demand demand
is your you're insisting and you're
pleading and and and maybe even your
spanking but you're trying to control
your kids and they're doing what you
want
that's demanding and we all make demands
as parents but the goal is to be
commanding to be a commanding presence
where they
listen because they respect you and they
listen simply because you're saying it
and so you have command over the
household now nobody can do complete
that task perfectly obviously but that's
the goal and I think that spanking tends
to lend more towards the demanding
parenting style than commanding and then
three I think there are real ethical
concerns with using physical force
against a child with trying to extract
good behavior through physical force and
the fear of physical force I know a lot
of people grow up in homes where they
feared their dads and they behaved
because they were afraid of being
smacked and I know a lot of people
defend that saying I turned out okay but
whether you actually turned out okay or
not
I still don't think it's the right
approach or the right relationship
you're supposed to have with your child
you think about think about a child's
it's a very small frail helpless
creature we're talking about here and I
don't know imposing yourself physically
in that way using physical force on a
small child as an adult I think there
should be other ways and there are other
ways you should be able to one thing you
should be able to outsmart your child
and I think when you resort to spanking
what you're saying is I got nothing else
and you've beaten me you beat me in the
psychological game and so now I'm gonna
beat you and I know look okay I I know
people are gonna say is a difference
between beating and smacking a spanking
III understand that but it is still
you're physically hitting your child
right that is what you're doing
so I understand the distinction may be
between beating and spanking but
sometimes parents who spank their
children I think they're in a little bit
of denial they try they even try to draw
distinctions between hitting a child and
spanking no you are hitting you are
dictionary definition that's hitting you
are hitting the child to get the child
to behave and when you put it like
that it sounds kind of awful and but
that's the correct way of putting it
because that is what you're doing right
I and is going back to I think I think
there are things we do as parents
spanking maybe is one of them where
people do it primarily because their
parents did it and their parents did it
in their parents did it and it's it's
it's sort of a normal thing for parents
to do I think that's the main reason
people do it not because they've looked
at research that convinced them not
because they've really thought about the
ethical implications of it maybe I know
they're exceptions maybe you have but I
think for a lot of parents they do it
just because it's what their parents did
and I'm not saying that this generation
of parents that we're all better than
the previous generations but and I know
but but the problem is a lot of people
will say there seemed to think that
previous generations of parents were so
much better than us and so we should
just do what they did and there's this
idealization that happens of the
previous old you know the old fashioned
parenting they got some things right
that we get wrong certainly but they
also got some things horribly wrong as
well they weren't perfect parents and
and they did have some wrong ideas about
parenting we shouldn't idolize that you
think even the greatest generation come
the greatest generation oh they knew how
to parent yeah well their kids turned
around and started the sexual revolution
so I'm not putting the blame entirely on
them but the the the evidence that they
were wonderful awesome parents isn't
there they something obviously went
really wrong with your great parents
your your so-called great parenting and
then you know next thing you know your
kids are starting Woodstock I think some
things went wrong and when you hear
these people talk about oh my
grandmother used to pull out the belt
and yeah you know they talk about their
fathers or their grandparents using
belts and weapons and in anger hitting
them and people talk about it out almost
fine
with nostalgia but what you're
describing is an adult is an
out-of-control enraged adult using a
weapon against you as a child that is
physical abuse you are you are you are
fondly recalling your own abuse and then
claiming you turned out fine
I think that's evidence that you didn't
turn out fine and you know back in the
old days especially with fathers I think
there was this wasn't the case across
the board but the general attitude was
fathers were more emotionally distant
they were authority figures but that was
kind of it they were more emotionally
distant they didn't interact with the
kids as much there wasn't as much
affection there wasn't as much playing
with the kid on their own level as a
father and so you sort of feared your
father as an authority figure but I
think that's wrong I think this is one
area where in in modern times we have
improved where a father and have my own
kids you know a very affectionate with
my kids I play with my kids I don't want
to just be the authority figure in the
home I want to be someone a source of
love and affection as well I want to be
someone that they feel safe around and
what it feels to be someone that they
can relate to and have a bond with and
talk I want to be that - I'm not saying
you can't do that if you spank I'm just
saying that there were some that the the
philosophy of parenting back in the old
days was not entirely correct there were
some problems with it and I think that
spanking may have been a part of that so
it's just something we should analyze
and think about all right let's go this
is from Aaron says dear Matt but one
other point about this I want to make a
sum it up here maybe this is all I
needed to say rather than rambling for
15 minutes most people would say that
hitting a dog as punishment his animal
abuse
certainly hitting a dog with a belt or
any kind of a rod or anything a spoon
whatever most people would say
especially if you're using some sort of
tool hitting a dog that's abuse if there
was a video of a guy and I'm sure there
are videos like this online there's a
video of a guy with a belt whipping his
dog we would all say not only is that
animal abuse but that animal should be
taken away and that guy should go to
jail and yet it's okay to hit a kid are
we really gonna say that there are
disciplinary methods that are unethical
to use against animals but are okay
against young children and I I do think
there's a distinction between say using
a belt and just using your hand but
there are people that do the belt too
and there are people at least who maybe
don't use the belt themselves but we'll
excuse it you're whipping a child and
again you if anyone did that to a dog
they'd go to jail so I think it goes the
other way around that there is there is
no ethical form of punishment against
the child that I can think of that would
be unethical against a dog there are
ethical forms of punishments for dogs
that would be unethical for children so
it does go the other way like crating
for instance okay but if you're doing
something your kid that would enrage you
if you saw someone do it to a dog that
should be a red flag yeah that's all
saying okay from aaron says dear Matt
yesterday you were criticizing people
who brought up kobe bryant's rape
accusation for 2003 by pointing out that
he was never convicted of anything
so it's unfair to speak with confidence
as if you know for sure he's guilty you
even went so far as to say that people
were slandering him for talking about it
last year you said that Michael Jackson
was a child rapist despite the fact that
he liked Kobe has never been convicted
in a court of law you even criticize
people who pointed this out by stating
that it's too high of a standard to say
you won't believe something negative
about someone unless they've been
convicted of it my question then is
which is it why is it okay to call
Michael Jackson a rapist but not Kobe
when both were never convicted and yes
and please don't say we we don't call
Kobe a rapist out of respect for the
dead Michael Jackson's been dead for ten
years and that didn't stop you from
saying what you said about him I think
there's a delineation here Aaron
a fair point but I think it was a
delineation first of all my primary
criticism of people who brought the Kobe
stuff is that they did it literally
hours after he died and there's no
reason for that the man died by the way
died along with his daughter and ate up
seven other people and there were there
were those who the first thing they did
the first thing they said bodies still
smoldering in the wreck and their first
move is to call him a rapist that's
obviously in bad taste to say the least
there's no reason I'm not saying that we
can never talk about the negative things
of about someone's life after they die
obviously that would be absurd but you
don't you don't need to do it in this
case five minutes later there's there's
no reason for it other than to get
attention and so that was my primary
beef but also Kobe Bryant was accused
one time by one person wasn't convicted
the evidence against him was not in my
opinion overwhelming I'm not saying he's
innocent I don't know but I think based
on what we do know it's unreasonable
forget about the timing for a minute
even it's unreasonable to think or to
speak with confidence and say that he's
guilty now for Michael Jackson on the
other hand you've got a man who was
multiple-- accused of child rape by
multiple children telling similar
stories
there's bundles of evidence against him
eyewitness and physical evidence and he
admits to having little boys over to his
house and even in his bed for sleepovers
as I said before and I'll say it again
if you think a grown man is inviting
little boys into his bed for innocent
reasons you are not smart
and if you still think it even after
those little boys tell you they were
raped
you're a lot worse than not smart and I
would contend there is not a single
person on earth who would insist on
Michael Jackson's innocence given the
evidence against him given his own
admission to having sleepover parties
with with with with little boys who he
invited into his bed given all the
accusations nobody on earth would be
insisting on his innocence if they
didn't if if if he wasn't a famous pop
star if he was just Michael mr. Michael
Jackson down the street works as a
plumber or works at the DMV or something
and all of these facts lined up against
him and you found out that he was that
he was having little boys from the
neighborhood over to his house for
sleepovers and then oh by the way a few
of them have even said that they were
raped there is no way in hell you would
be insisting that he's innocent no way
not one single person would the only
reason they're doing with Michael
Jackson is because they like the way he
dances and sings and I find that just I
find that attitude to be really beneath
with contempt that you would give
someone the benefit of the doubt because
you like their songs that's not the case
of Kobe with Kobe Bryant I'm you know I
was never I was never a big Kobe fan I
wasn't no I didn't dislike him I just I
didn't have much of an opinion about it
one way or another
and so with his rape case I'm not
looking at it like oh no my dear Kobe
never could have done that because I
like the way he plays basketball that's
not my approach I I looked at the case
back when it first was was in the news
back in 2003 or whenever it was I've
looked at it again this week and I just
think and it's the only case against him
he wasn't convicted and there's there're
a lot of details in that case that that
cast doubt such as just one of the
details by the way is that from from
what I read that
when they did the the rape kit on the on
the accuser they found other men's DNA
as well not just kobe bryant's so that
alone right there is enough for
reasonable doubt alright but thank you
for the the email and we will wrap it up
there thanks everybody for watching and
listening have a great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]